this item is being sold by a Russian
billionaire who bought it for 127
million dollars four years ago was he
selling well I think it's a good time to
be selling actually and I think he's
probably taking advantage of the current
market situation a lot of people are
arguing that because this pictures been
retouched so many times there's precious
little Leonardo in it is that a
justifiable complaint no I don't think
it is I mean this picture is a 500 year
old picture
and you know you in these sorts of
situations with with with rare pictures
like this on panel they get damaged over
the years and and and there are
retouches that's quite normal unlike the
National Gallery in London has many many
paintings that have been retouched this
has been done very sympathetically and
there are still very good surviving
areas I think you know the the hand
raised in benediction the right Christ's
right hand is is beautifully preserved
the the celestial globe made of rock
crystal that Leonardo has very carefully
painted even with all the little
inclusions these damages in the rock
crystal a beautifully preserved so you
know it is it is a Leonardo yes it is it
has suffered over the years some of the
glazes get sort of cleaned off over the
years of wreak leaning and nian either
had an unusual technique I mean he would
you use incredibly intensive small thin
layers of pigments would be layered upon
layer it took years to produce these
paintings so they do get damaged when
they're not treated you know correctly
now the interesting thing is this is
being sold in a sale of Contemporary Art
why is that well it's a good question
and it's it's you know it does has
raised a few eyebrows I think auction
houses and Christie's in particular have
often blurred the categories when they
when they sell things never quite as
Extreme as this of Renaissance master
being sold in a contemporary sale but I
think it's a it's an acknowledgment
really that the the really big sales
these days take place in post-war
contemporary and modern paintings and
with this price tag on it
you know you've you're really looking
for the big big buyers your on who's
gonna buy it then I mean it's not going
to be a museum is it
well a museum the museum's interested in
buying this and of course there are a
lot of very very wealthy people who you
know create their own museums so this
will be a fantastic piece for a museum
we're looking at a very small number of
people someone with very very deep
pockets is going to buy this it may be
an Asian buyer Asian buyers have been
very active recently and in the
marketplace buying Asian art but also
Western paintings as well it could be a
South American buyer and I think
Christie's have probably been you know
showing it around in California hoping
that one of the big tech giants might
buy it I mean let's not remember
remember actually that Leonardo's codex
was once bought by Bill Gates so I think
that's another area of interest